you're lying
unbelievable you know this is kind of
like this is your life
[Music]
hi I'm Donnie Osmond and this is my ET
retrospective and we're going to go
through some of my most iconic moments
this clip is my very first appearance on
the Andy Williams Show I was five years
old
[Music]
I had no idea what roller coaster I've
just hopped on to there's these little
things called cameras they said when
they turn red that camera is on you
so I said sure okay he said I gotta do
this the rest of my life this is awesome
anybody see my glasses
the seven little boys
what's the big idea I've been studying
too hard
I've been studying to it I remember
rehearsing that line over and over and
over again I think that's probably where
my I got my sad card
the next one is the Donnie and Marie
show now this isn't Marie on my
shoulders obviously come out and I do a
spin and I drop her something breaks
boom
I'm Donny Osmond you can come out now
Marie and then Marie comes out she took
a little too long to come out this is my
kid's sister and that's how we
introduced Donnie and Marie we had no
idea that this was going to blossom into
what the Donnie and Marie Duo became but
it was so powerful not just in the
United States but around the world but I
spent most of my childhood here in
Southern California my very first ET
interview back in 1981. my lifelong
dream was to be the first singer on the
moon
and
when I found out that when they went up
there they left a tape an audio tape of
a song called Aquarius I was singing
backgrounds on that song they left a
tape up there my voice is sitting on the
moon okay
let me tell you what's going through my
mind right there
I really don't like
my image I had just opened and closed on
Broadway
in a show called Little Johnny Jones
we opened and closed
one day one show that's embarrassing
Donny Osmond was a joke on the streets I
realized I gotta reinvent myself and
then reinvention process began
for the next seven years
my Soldier of Love video
oh I love that song
I'll give you a little back story on
this one I had to create a new Donnie
Michael Jackson
so I asked him how do I get back on the
charts Mike
he said Your name's poison you got to
change your name
uh gee what an insult but he was right
because Soldier of Love became a massive
hit
without my name and then they found out
who it was perfect marketing our very
first guess Pamela Anderson Lee Donnie
and Marie talk show so everyone thought
Pamela Anderson with Donnie and Marie
isn't that like oil and water I said yes
and that's why it works you can kind of
fight the whole goody goody image that
we had back then
uh or you can make it work for you and
that's how that's why the show worked
because so we had so many so many
amazing people on that show okay you
have to introduce yourself Beyonce
Donnie
introducing Beyonce that was kind of
cool
and I thought wow this girl's talented
she's going to go someplace
[Music]
Britney Spears uh we were one of the
first well we were the first we debuted
the Britney Spears on uh television
my dancing performance on Miss America
oh
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
nobody expected that kind of dancing and
that kind of that kind of GrooVe from
Donny Osmond looks shocked we rehearsed
that thing over and over and over again
and uh
it was live I have one tape I did a one
take because it's live
my heart was pumping and I was so
excited to do this thing
when we had finished that thing I went
like just like that to the camera the
place erupted
and I've got my sights set on that one I
got my eye set on that one I know beauty
and the beast on Broadway oh my goodness
that was a fun experience
getting back on Broadway and
particularly playing the role of Gaston
it's true
and they said after 17 years we want you
to be the final guest on
and I think back of that that play that
I did a little Johnny Jones I opened and
closed in one show right I said well
you've called the right man because I
know how to close a show
We Wish You a Merry Christmas
[Applause]
College Road Trip
where do I start on that one you know
people said you know you've worked so
hard to change your image and then you
do this
I'm really dorky in this this role
and so I said I could tone this down or
it can really go for it boy did I go for
it there was a scene with Martin
Lawrence
and I went and talked to the director
and I said I was going to kiss him on a
cheek
and it's not in the script and he said
go for it
the hardest face this is like
what did you just do
ttie
oh man the emotions going through my
through me right now I have never worked
harder in my life
for an Accolade than Dancing with the
Stars
right there
see that right there Tom was about to
give me that trophy that I worked so
hard for and I wouldn't accept it
until I went over to the audience and
picked up my wife and carried her onto
the Dance Floor
because
she went through a lot
Watching Me dance with another woman so
the trophy belongs to Debbie not me
ladies and Justice is the moment you've
been waiting for
[Music]
[Laughter]
I was the very first math singer
we felt the electricity in the room they
said at that moment we knew we had a hit
show
[Music]
it All Began back in Utah I was four
years old started singing with my
brothers and the sound was like ghosts
guest hosting on ET that was a fun
interview I always loved coming on E.T
you guys always make it fun and that was
uh that's part of the 10 minute wrap in
my show here in Vegas I know it sounds
funny Donny Osmond doing a wrap but it's
it's my entire career in 10 minutes
[Music]
come on that one of a kind rap in his
Vegas residency Donnie will soon hit the
road in a limited U.S tour kicking off
in July I put six Decades of show
business in a 90-minute show
[Applause]